[Music]
[Applause]
we make way for uh chris maddox mannix
has been all over this uh possibility of
a trade between the brooklyn nets and
the boston celtics um
how real is this chris the possibility
that kevin durant and the celtics could
maybe pull off a deal
the nets are
in a way running out of options with
kevin durant
um
you know they couldn't put a deal
together involving phoenix and that's
when phoenix had deandre ayton
as a potential tradeship that's off the
board now because ayton's new contract
prevents him from being traded
um at least in that first year
um miami
you can't trade bam adebayo to brooklyn
with ben simmons on the roster because
of league rules and
i don't get the sense miami has an
appetite to deal
bam adebayo as it is you know toronto is
not giving up scotty barnes in a deal
for for kevin durant so the number of
potential suitors
is pretty limited out there and boston's
out there with a bona fide all-star in
jaylen brown draft picks which as i said
they're unafraid to deal and swap rights
whatever you want to do and ancillary
pieces that they could throw into the
pot that might satisfy brooklyn so i
it's a long way of saying i believe
there's real teeth to to the possibility
of kevin durant winding up in boston
let's look at jalen brown's situation he
was the celtics best player in the
finals probably looks around and goes
wait a minute you've tried to trade me a
couple of times now uh anthony davis
kawhi leonard it felt like he was going
to be involved in those trades he's 25
two years left on this deal
is is what's is he or was he in the long
term plans for the celtics
look i think jalen's always been
part of the long-term plans for the
celtics
except if you can get a transcendent
player i mean jaylen brown has not been
talked about in deals that would net a
player
the equivalent of jaylen brown the names
you mentioned kawhi leonard which was a
topic when leonard was being dealt from
san antonio anthony davis when davis was
at the peak of his powers playing in new
orleans now kevin durant an all-nba guy
who has four years remaining on his
contract it's just jaylen brown is the
most movable piece
uh on this roster now
the celtics might be getting themselves
into a bit of a pickle with brown for
for some of the reasons that that you
talked about i mean brown
even though it has been for players who
are elite
has been talked about in trades
every single year i mean you go back to
jaylen brown's draft night dan he was
booed his selection was booed on draft
night in boston for by some fans that
wanted them to take chris dunn
in that draft so he's had kind of a
rollercoaster ride
uh in this city so the celtics have to
wonder
if all these trade talks have poisoned
the well in a way with jaylen brown he
saw him tweet something on monday
uh that seemed to suggest he was
a little bit frustrated the other part
of this
is that jaylen brown does have two years
remaining on his contract but
it's not a contract that's likely to be
extended
for financial reasons jaylen brown took
what turned out to be
a below market value contract when he
signed one a few years ago and because
of that he can't turn around
and sign a max level extension
next summer with this team there are
limits to how much boston can offer him
in an extension they can go all out and
offer him a five-year max when hits free
agency
in 2024
but that's a risk like jalen brown will
be an unrestricted free agent in 2024
and he could look around say you know
what
i'm tired of all this trade talk i want
to go to a place where i can be either a
more appreciated or b be in a position
to be the lead man on that team i
believe i have the talent to ultimately
do that and the celtics could wind up
losing him for nothing so there are a
couple reasons why boston might be
motivated to to get deeper into this mix
okay what happens next does it come from
the nets
in what they want or does it come from
the celtics since this is where it
originated
whether it's the celtics or any other
team interested in kevin durant it now
becomes
kind of a game of chicken where
everybody kind of retires to their
corner for a few weeks and
waits to see
what kind of plays out for teams that
are interested in durant including
boston
they want to see what brooklyn's
appetite really is for bringing the band
back together i mean the nets want the
league to believe
that they are willing to bring back
kevin durant kyrie irving and because of
that there's no sense of urgency to do
that there's skepticism among some of
the league officials that i've talked to
that brooklyn really is willing to do
that so
the way i'm kind of reading the room
here dan is that
everyone
is off for a few weeks maybe they're
already off right now
um go on vacation all that and then
mid to late august maybe even early
september you kind of reconvene take the
temperature of the of their respective
teams now brooklyn may decide you know
what we can't do this kevin durant
doesn't want to be here we're not going
to bring him back we're not going to
have a circus on our hand
with with durant back in town they'll
say you know what jalen brown derek
white
throw in grant williams and maybe we can
make a deal or the alternative is the
nets could say you know what no deal
unless we get what we want and the
celtics
may be faced with having to decide
whether or not to include marcus smart
in a deal i personally think that you
could probably get it done with jaylen
brown marcus smart and a whole bunch of
draft picks and swaps but the celtics
understandably don't want to do that
marcus smart took a lot of criticism
after the finals but this is a reigning
defensive player of the year still in
his 20s still at or near the top of his
game they don't want to move marcus
smart but it it may come down to that
decision when we get into late august
but if you're the celtics
we're going to pass on kevin durant
because we don't want to give up marcus
smart
it's two starters dan
real real assets real value that they'd
be giving up it's kevin durant
it is kevin durant which is why
i wouldn't hesitate to
trade jaylen brown who is 25 and has the
potential to be an all-star all-nba
player for the next 10 years it's a risk
there because durant's injury history
has to leave you a little bit leery to
be 34 years old in september but i'd
still do it
adding
marcus smart into that mix a player that
has been integral to what they do
defensively that might be a little bit
too much for the selfies to swallow
especially when you consider
that yeah if you believe vegas i mean
they're going into next season as like
the co-favorite that's why i wouldn't do
anything chris well no i mean i i
wouldn't do i again just me speaking i
probably wouldn't do both i wouldn't
throw marcus smart and jaylen brown into
that mix but if you're just effectively
flipping jaylen brown for kevin durant
plus and derek white plus draft picks oh
i can't do that of course yeah that
opens that opens a four year window
right there yeah for for you to win
multiple championships you know people
out there
have taken the opinion the celtics
should do nothing they should stand pat
i've read that a lot because the celtics
are considered a favorite i can tell you
even if they are listed as a favorite
and by oddsmakers in vegas and whoever
there's not a comfort in boston that
they are the favorite they know they
were probably a chris middleton injury
away from losing in the second round
they were jimmy butler jump shot away
from losing in the conference finals
they're looking around and going
philadelphia just reloaded atlanta is
gonna be better cleveland's gonna be
better hell they could be one you know
not even major injury away from losing
in the first round in next year's
playoffs that's how little the margin
for error is you add kevin durant that
margin increases significantly for next
season he's chris mannix he covers the
nba nba senior writer for sports
illustrated the donovan mitchell
situation it certainly was front burner
and then it cooled off um are we looking
at the same time frame if something
happens in a couple of weeks
i i think it could be that but it's
almost more likely to be even longer um
i feel like some of these reports that
are coming out there
about mitchell to the knicks or is
almost wishful thinking
um on behalf of some look i i wrote this
uh today on si.com like this is
this is exactly the kind of situation
danny ainge wants to be in if he's not
competing for a championship
this is the situation he wants to be in
to have a young
highly talented player that he doesn't
really
want to have on the roster anymore
because he wants to go into a rebuild um
with three years left in his contract
and multiple suitors out there like dave
with rudy gobert
danny found someone that was just
desperate he just smells desperation on
teams really well and minnesota came in
and offered those four draft picks and
young players and got a deal done
someone whether it's a few weeks from
now a few months from now the trade
deadline someone's going to get
desperate there are some obvious choices
or candidates out there right now the
knicks
they could get desperate they've wanted
donovan mitchell for years now leon rose
used to represent him caa in new york uh
miami if boston gets durant and other
teams move around the sixers picked up
pieces miami could say look
donovan mitchell's better than tyler
hero will throw tyler hero three first
round draft picks whatever else on the
side that you want phoenix
look that was a tough exit for phoenix
in the playoffs they could say look
mchale bridges plus every draft pick
we've got to go get you donovan mitchell
all i can tell you is this damn
danny is going to win this trade he is
he's just going to win this trade he's
going to find somebody out there that is
just crazy and wants to get donovan
mitchell so bad they're willing to give
the kind of package that
would almost make a durant deal look
look tame by comparison somebody out
there is going to do it
thank you chris
you got it dan that's chris mannix
covers the nba for sports illustrator
bringing up some interesting thoughts
about this and if you're jaylen brown
and they know he's not going to be there
long term then maybe you start to
sweeten the deal